we'll be joined then by steve richards
and claire foxx and at the start they're
having a story about
appearances claire and this is our first
time we've seen you actually since
you yourself were awarded one so first
of all huge congratulations on that
um you'd have seen there's been a fair
amount of coverage over the weekend
about all the appointments but
yours has also raised some questions
some people raising a few eyebrows about
you
accepting a peerage when you've talked
about wanting to abolish the house of
laws haven't you
i have indeed and that actually if you
look at the
uh green um uh candidates and or you
know the
baronesses the two green baronesses they
also want to abolish the house of lords
i think there's a tradition of that i
appreciate that people will level the
charge of hypocrisy against me but i
just think that although it's an
unelected chamber
i do think it's an affront to democracy
i'm
also pleased to be given an opportunity
and a platform to
argue for things that i feel very
strongly about like free speech and
obviously some of the uh ideas
associated with brexit so
i've taken it i gave it some thought you
can imagine
okay and we are going to be um turning
to the papers in a moment in fact the
first story we're talking about is john
hume so i'm just going to raise one of
the other issues that's come up
in the coverage about your appointment
and some have criticized the appointment
because they say that you were
associated with an organization that
failed to contend the ira that defended
the ira so what do you what do you make
of that criticism
well it is true that i was involved in
revolutionary politics a long time ago
and there will have been views that i
had then
that i think at the time were part and
parcel of politics as they were
understood
including on ireland and they are very
controversial today but it was a long
time ago
and one thing i'd say about john hume
we're going to go and
talk about him who is a a titan and the
person he orchestrated the peace process
was that
he recognized that times move on
and that's what i'd say it was a long
time ago times have moved on
i understand people are very angry about
views i had 25
27 years ago that's life you know
i stand on what i say now